[Music]  you know it was a big surprise for me  when I was told that I was gonna wear a  from the zebra to be an Angels a big  deal and then to get the Fantasy Bra is  like crazy when it happened for me I  just immediately started crying and like  dropped into tears the Fantasy Bra is  the most special piece in the run away  when I stepped on the runway  my number one thought was don't cry  because it was such a special moment to  me and Asda models everyone we all want  to wear it you know it's the highlight  of the show she just feels so preciate  it and thankful and it really solidifies  your journey as an angel it's amazing  enjoy the moment you deserve it you  worked so hard for this I would just say  to go out there and get it because it's  your time to shine  [Music]